la route que prennent les morts et les
endeuillés depuis vernis tôt cette route
sur le bord de la baie du son elle
s'appelle sna icub ulliac ce qui veut
dire en innu petit tout route du
dépotoir sur la montagne d'objets tout
juste derrière le cimetière des jeunes
traînent cherche des trésors ce qu'on
appelle ici la dombes est un endroit
très fréquenté
les gens appellent cela le kennedy
d'ailleurs on vient chercher ce qui nous
manque
on essaie de trouver des pièces pour
réparer les 4 ou par exemple cela coûte
moins cher que de les faire venir par
bateau explique cette résidente de
puvirnituq
le nunavik ses quatorze villages dont on
peut sortir que par avion ou par bateau
ce sont donc 14 dépotoir où les déchets
qu'on ne put enfouir dans ce hall
s'accumulent car tout ce qui monte au
nord ne redescend pas douze mille tonnes
par année de restes de chantier et de
toutes sortes de choses
parmi elles des batteries des baril
d'huile bref pas mal de produits
toxiques
dans l'immense beauté des paysages du
nord ces déchets forme d'un outrage
nous avons amené les jeunes rencontrés
au dépotoir de puvirnituq prendre un
café pour parler ordures
au départ ils se sont étonnés du sujet
ils ont ri du fait qu'une équipe de
télévision s'intéresse à ça et pourtant
le sujet les touches chaise géante amont
et revus je trouve ça anxiogène
d'immoral quan à luc 21 ans riche
c'est grandiose est limitée par pierre
roussel est arrivé à coups de jouarres
apic le village le plus méridional du
nunavik en 1981 il devait y rester un an
il y est toujours amoureux de sa nature
il est gestionnaire au village c'est
plus les déchets avec des appareils
domestiques
mais c'est un tout et pour tout les
beaucoup de contrôler la vienne tigerman
mandat du hcr contrôle des municipalités
un peu sceptique sur le sujet qui doit
être fermé on a amené beaucoup de des
ferrailles à voir si on ne tient pas un
intérêt mais il n'y en a pas dans
l'avion c'est impensable il faut que ce
soit un film à part mettre au point que
ça pour les produits la drachme sauf que
ce soit y emballé d'une façon conforme
au plan de transport bateau quelque
chose comme ça ça fait cinq ans
un peu quand ça brûle ça pue dit c'est
la cie quand les matières combustibles
et les eaux usées sont éliminés par le
feu on les fait brûler assez ouvert pour
éviter les animaux sauvages pour éviter
aussi une accumulation qui est trop
grande
puisqu'on peut plus qui se décomposent
pas donc on les fait brûler à ciel
ouvert au mail free dedans donc la
contamination de l'air et donc des
populations environnantes
audry son chagrin et la seule chercheurs
ou québec à s'être intéressé à ce
problème
loin d'être prioritaire en regard des
autres
toi faux lent suicide pénurie de
logements toxicomanie décrochage
scolaire entre autres aux environnements
c'est sûr que c'est important mais ça va
passer des fois peut-être après parce
qu'il ya des problèmes qui sont beaucoup
plus urgents il ya des villages qui
envoie les vieux pneus d'un successeur
qu'on devrait faire envoyer le plus de
choses dans ce disque lacie sait déjà
qu'à pour les canettes et les vieux
appareils électroniques qui prendront le
bateau et seront recyclés à montréal
tout doucement aussi on commence à
évacuer des sols contaminés des
meilleurs lifetime dr antisida de ce
pays
et non comme des suspects mourad crois
qu'un jour ces dépotoirs ne seront plus
qu'un souvenir
son ami salah ci vit un peu ils seront
toujours là dit il
on en a besoin selon un plan de
l'autorité régionale du nunavik écrit en
les dépotoirs devrait éventuellement
être au moins plus sécuritaire et munis
de membranes pour protéger les sols
émilie dubreuil radio canada nous avait
dit